Hello everyone, and welcome to today's class on Sequencer, Introduction for Linear Content.
My name is Brian Poole, and I'll be your authorized Unreal instructor throughout this
course.
This class is a follow-up from the Quickstart Sequencer class on shock construction.
We will readdress some of the content from that class, but we'll also go beyond those
lessons by examining more advanced workflows.
Here's a quick look at what we'll be covering today.
In overview, we'll begin by asking the question of what is virtual production, and what are
the benefits of using Unreal Engine for linear content.
Then we'll re-examine some of the core concepts of sequencer's capabilities like what is
sequencer, what is a level sequence, and we'll discuss actor persistence types.
That will be followed by an examination of core structures in sequencer, define a few
terms, and compare Unreal Sequencer to the structure of film production.
Next we'll take a look at sequencer's interface, discuss event management, curve editing, and
setting up level sequence templates.
Plus, we'll spend some time learning about Unreal cameras and their components, take
recorder, live link face, and VCAM.
In hands-on, shock creation and assembly, we'll focus on how to actually set up a nested
level sequence assembly, how it's different from using just a single camera cuts track
alone, and how it ties to the shot track, sub-scene tracks, and other advanced functionality.
This will be followed by a practical exercise.
And then finally, in final recommendations, we'll talk about level organization, folder
structures, and sequencer best practices, and then look into potential tips and resources.
Alright, let's get started.
These class will be utilizing the SEQ-10502 map level in the SEQ-90505 project file.
It can be downloaded under content, courses, course maps.
The project file you've downloaded contains items associated with four different courses.
We will be examining the course SEQ-10502.
Our goal for this course is to expand our knowledge of sequencer by understanding the
basics of creating multiple shots using nested level sequences.
This project will utilize a level, multiple level sequences, and contain a character,
multiple cameras, camera cuts tracks, and a shot track.
This approach is the more advanced of two sequencer assembly methods, whereas the first
method only leverages a single level sequence and a single camera cuts track, this version
showcases nested level sequences for more advanced shot creation and flexibility.
After you've downloaded the zip file and extracted its contents, you should see the
SEQ-90501-55 project file.
This file was created in Unreal 5.5, so if you have an early version of the engine, you
should upgrade.
If you have a later version of Unreal, you'll have to convert the project file to Unreal
5.6 or higher by following the prompts Unreal provides for you upon launching this project.
The primary map should automatically load, but in case it doesn't, let's take a look
as to where you can find it.
Inside the content folder, there is a course folder.
This folder contains a course maps folder.
Within here, you'll find maps for all four courses within this project.
In case your level didn't open upon launch, let's double click on the SEQ-10502 map.
This will bring up Rural Australia.
This is a really great map with some very realistic models and textures.
What's even better is that it's highly optimized and can run on most computers and GPUs with
ease.
This map can be found on FAP in case you're interested in having it in your own library.
If you're curious as to where the assets are for this level, they're located in the
assets folder inside Rural Australia.
And if we take a look over here in the Outliner, everything is nicely organized into folders
and named beautifully with a dedicated naming convention.
The level sequence we'll be examining and ultimately recreating is located in the course
folder inside of the SEQ-10502 folder.
Then open course topics, shot creation folder, and finally the multi-shot EX folder.
Our level sequence is SEQ-multi-shot EX.
If you'd like to take a look, double click on the level sequence icon.
This will open the Sequencer UI and you'll be allowed to view the sequence by clicking
on the camera icon in the shots track and then pressing play.
This will show you the three level sequence shots being played back-to-back in sequence.
In our next module, we'll take a look at a brief overview of using Sequencer for virtual
production and for the creation of linear content.
Then we'll move on to core concepts and structure behind Sequencer and understand how Sequencer
fundamentals operate.